we will fix the injustice of care home
funding
we will fix the crisis in social care
once
and for all with a clear plan we have
prepared
two years since this promise ten years
since the dilnut report on reforming
social care and today another delay
a key meeting between the prime minister
health secretary and chancellor called
off
with post-pandemic costs mounting across
the board the man behind that original
blueprint a decade ago
is frustrated i think it's a stain on
our nation we're talking
about the well-being of the most
vulnerable people in our society
and their families there are one and a
half million people working
in social care as many as in the nhs now
feels like the time and i do think that
kovid has shown
a particularly harsh light on the
arrangements in the social care sector
sandra oh well done so what might the
plan look like
a cap on how much of our own money we
have to spend on care is likely and
better training for staff is also being
discussed
private insurance could be on the table
too government sources say
but the big question looms how do we pay
the 10 billion pound bill
the government has to admit and
we all have to admit that the reason why
successive governments
have failed to address this is that we
have to spend more on social care
that money has to come from somewhere i
think a mixed approach to finding that
funding partly
taxation partly private contributions is
the sensible way to do it but it does
need significant extra money there is no
way of disguising that
and while politicians in westminster
debate it's the nhs
and our parents and grandparents in care
homes like this one in west yorkshire
who suffer there are four million people
who are caring for people
in this country we need reform we need
it now but it's false economy
what bit of this don't they understand
if there is no social care
people will deteriorate longer at home
they will require more home care
more district nurses more chiropody
everything
it's false economy beds will be blocked
we just do not have the capacity
without social care surviving boris
johnson knows he has to deliver on his
very public promise but the scale of the
challenge is overwhelming
a cap on contributions rather than more
fundamental reform will solve
some but not all of the issues but
experts fear we still haven't answered
the question
what kind of life should we be providing
for older people in the years to come
kate mccann sky news